it's worth doing a quick recap of how we
expect the parameter this to behave
again it's almost exactly like an input
parameter but rather than being bound to
the value that is supplied between the
parens it's bound to the value that's on
the left of the dot at call time so this
function is going to log first OB one
and then OB two here are the call time
parens and this is the binding for the
first positional parameter and here we
have the call time dot and the binding
for the parameter this back in our
example these are the call time parens
there's nothing being passed in and
bounded the positional parameters and
here we have the call time dot and the
binding for the parameter this